today's topic um and so
somebody we know a man brought up a
thing he said you know sometimes i meet
women who are older
and they've been very promiscuous and it
bothers me because i hate the idea of
walking into a room
and she may have like with some of the
other dudes
in the room or whatever and i said to be
fair
you know you're not what i said that's
what you said
and to be fair
and hold on before we do we go on in
this
we have to establish a certain rule
okay because then we go out and we say
the word
like that and to your definition it
might be super
bad for me uh being a or being in a
phase it's a thing it's not good
it's not bad yes there are costs they're
consequences
but it's a thing i don't frown upon you
i don't care about that i don't care
about like if a girl
slept with a whole lot of men or
whatever what not to me
and i was saying that this i was saying
after the same dude i was like listen
if you wanna if you wanna you're gonna
need girls that do it too
you want to do it you're going to need
girls that do it yeah
so yeah yeah let's just put that in
perspective but go ahead
no i'm entitled to agree at the end of
the day we're like it's not something to
shame people it's just a fact he is what
he is
you know what i'm saying can't look at
her sideways when you've done just as
much dirt
you go you go and then audacity what
yeah the audacity bro i know you you
gonna look at a girl and you're gonna be
like oh i i've been in nightclubs with
you and like
half the girls you did you know you're
going to have these
i dance with a girl and i'm like yo she
got that special sauce you gave her you
feel me like
you go it is
it is what it is
it is what it is i can't i can't do
nothing about that
but the main thing is like he felt like
you know it's different when a guy does
it because if a man
it's a lot of women doesn't have the
thing i'm a key
and she a lock yeah you wanna key that
opens all the
locks you don't want to unlock that gets
opened by all the keys
no she's a human being and you're a
human being and we have needs
a key don't have need a lock don't have
need it's
it's more complicated than that and just
because a metaphor sounds good
okay it doesn't mean that it brings true
okay
so that's why i always find it funny
when dudes like go out and do their dirt
and then look at women who do their dirt
as if they're better i'm like bro you've
you you've soiled yourself as well i'm
all the strip club and be like yo look
at that stripper i'm like [ __ ] you
in the strip club with her if she going
to hell
you going to hell what you talking about
yeah yeah it's crazy
it's hypocritical but it raised a good
question right it raised the question of
well what is the price to pay for male
promiscuity because we see it a lot of
times we glorify
we think it's awesome and i say there is
a cost
there's a cost there's a cost it's not
just women who who pay with their social
reputation or whatever this stuff
even men pay with their soulful
reputation definitely get around enough
you're going to pay
you're going to pay that's a point
people talk it is what it is
right and if it's not that and you
actually see it right now even with
celebrities celebrities who want to play
willy nilly
a lot of them have had to pay does that
not lie
right ask kevin hey what's up kev
all right but move it even beyond the
promiscuity thing right
there's also a cost in terms of this is
a weird one
you are indulging
because you lack the reason why you are
gluttonous
is because you lack discipline pinor
it's not because something feels good
that it is good
right fit out again right it's not
because you can play that you should
play play
but it's not because there's value in
something that you should value
value you know what i'm saying
i think especially for men there has to
be an honest discussion like
you do it because of eco right that
whole idea of like i'm trying to do
everything
i get it i know because i've done it
it's ego if we're being very honest with
this ourselves
and while you get to inflate your ego
and do all this stuff and go everywhere
and be in everybody
it doesn't mean that you're doing
something healthy for yourself and as
you spend time you start to realize like
what you're giving away and what it's
costing you right whether it's your time
whether it's your energy whether it's
your
emotion you know physical sanctity if
you believe in that kind of stuff
there's there's a price to pay any
indulgence in this world
you're going to pay a price and i think
especially with
things like bedroom stuff that price can
be very steep
very steep mentally you mean physically
too
if you catch the wrong thing yeah yeah i
mean every time you go in you roll some
dices
you think you'll be taxing you roll some
dices that could be taxi right
so there's that cost and you know that's
something that i had to record with a
couple years back where i started to
ask myself like a lot of questions in
regards to like why am i doing this
where is this coming from what does it
cost me because it doesn't feel great
mm-hmm
you know that high is there because it's
it's an addiction
it's an addiction yeah it's an addicting
sign the dopamines you get when you
when you go up to a girl you chat game
and she's down feels amazing
and you brag to your people yeah all
that stuff that people and
after that is the after that you feel
bad about it it could be right after you
bust
it could be the day after every time we
should be every time we
every time we bust we feel we feel
content or bad about some [ __ ]
there's levels yeah there's level three
there's levels definitely i think
once you kind of realize that about
yourself you have to you have to
you have to start tempering yourself and
i think um
you're in you're inherently trapped by
your desires
you are you know i still have little
lapses here and there on my
and i have to kind of try to bring
myself back because it's a constant
fight
uh because you mean not being able to
say no
it's hard it can be hard sometimes yeah
yeah yeah when it's been your crutch for
so long
to feel slightly better about yourself
it's hard to just walk away from that
and be like i'm good now yeah and so
that's something that i've had to learn
and if there's any advice i give to
young people
listen it's hard for me to sit on this
side of the fence and be like man you
don't need to
go through all that and touch all those
people and do all that stuff to get here
and feel good
because when you see it everywhere on
television and it's so glamorized the
the ladies man and all that stuff then
you want to go through that experience
and part of it is also true that it is a
good skill to be able to talk to
to women to feel comfortable and to do
all that stuff it's not a inherently bad
thing
but that overindulgence and that kind of
gluttonous behavior that we sometimes
have
towards intercourse and and just being
with women
that is very toxic whether it's one or a
man it's bad
so it's hard for me to tell young folks
to like maybe not try to dive into that
but i still leave you guys this message
that maybe one day
if you're sitting there and you're going
through and you're like why maybe you
remember this
i've told this to a couple of my people
before and like i got it and then they
started like man you're right and i'm
like i know cause i've been
i did what you did and then some so
it's hard it's hard because every day we
get fed this
every day we get told if you want to be
happy get women
if you want to be happy get their
affection what we don't get told
much about is discipline what we don't
get told much about
is how it's a sense of freedom to be
able to control yourself
we don't get taught these lessons and so
when you're trying to move through life
and to feel good about yourself you just
don't have much to fall back on
to me it's really it could it could be
good it could make you feel good it
could it can
help you actually to be on that side it
can but then again you have to
understand
why you're doing things and you have to
understand the dangers of
doing certain things like drugs you know
whenever you grow up they
always tell you they're bad things are
bad they're bad
kids are bad okay why does it look so
fun
because there's that fun side to it but
like abba said
it's not everything that feel good that
is
i'm not saying that all drugs are the
same or whatever what not that's a
different discussion or anything
but raising kids i'm not only going to
tell them that
they're bad because are bad there's that
but
you're taxing yourself there's a cost to
that
there's a cost whenever you indulge into
that but also what
what i have on my side is really what
what i understand is really just the
image that people have
of what it is to be promiscuous
especially guys in that side whenever
when you call out someone it's like it's
whack
it's it's a bit hypocritical if you want
to do these extra curricular activities
you need people to play you want to be
on the volleyball team
you need other teammates you can't just
smash balls
well whoa wait you can't just
do smashes like that alone you can but
it's it's not a game right
my father always told me
whenever you point somewhere there's
always three fingers that are pointing
at you
so you that's my dad you're the white
man
so you like doing instructor regular
activities you're going to need players
shaming is to me it's not it's not the
thing but whatever i think it's even
harder than that because you know you
say like
people be like it's taboo but really in
reality people encourage their sons
and to do a lot but they they they
restrict their daughters
they restrict their dogs but they
encourage their sons even though it's
it's super
negative for us as well but i just want
people to know like it's not just women
who pay a price
for that kind of you know you're paying
a price absolutely
it's it's an indication of a lack of
self-respect to think like you're just
gonna indulge because you have an urge
knowing that very well that you're
putting your health at risk every single
time just because you have a feeling
you know just because you have like a
little urge you think you don't think
there's a lack of self-respect there for
your own physical
well-being it's hard for me to reconcile
the two things you know what it reminds
me of it's like when you're young and
you can eat anything
cheeseburgers you stuff it all down and
then later on what happens
1 30 happens your metabolism
is not as fast as it used to be right
and then
you pack up some weight you cause
there's a confidence right
there's a gospel but then again you
didn't learn that discipline
when you were a kid it's going to be
harder when you're going to be older
yep you know most people that i know
they got us scared you know that's why
they they they into fitness now and
everything and stuff but yeah when they
was kid they were indulging in all kinds
of things
but it was drugs where there was food
but it was everything you know i mean
yep
but yeah yeah you know and i'm fortunate
that my price to pay was more so just on
the inside and stuff i got to deal with
but for other people it's
lifelong stuff for some people it's kids
out of wedlock with women that they
don't respect and don't want to be with
so they breed bad families for other
people it's situations where
um this person is now part of their life
because of the fact that they got slept
with like
there's crazy stuff that happens people
have had their careers ruined they've
had ruined other people's careers it's
crazy so
toxicity from generation to generation
probably even death i know dudes are
like i love married women
you're going to risk your life because
you got an urge
where is the self-respect where's the
discipline i'm not saying that having
a life in the bedroom with people is
necessarily bad understand why you're
doing it
understand can you discipline yourself
do you really have that ability if you
don't then you got a problem
you got a problem and it's hard to
acknowledge that but it is
and what grown men will tell you that
have gone through it and will stop
they'll tell you man
yeah a lot of it was not good that's
just my advice to y'all
um and just like my thoughts on the
topic
[Music]
foreign
this morning